yes I like being called couples goals
couples goals is right Nikki Bella and
artemchik Vince 'var engaged welcome
everyone and say hello to our special
co-host dancing partners turn real life
partners Nikki Bella and our though
really is you guys are very very sweet
that was in September and according to
their Instagram posts Nikki said yes to
Artem just two months later while they
were vacationing in France they both
posted these pics with Nikki writing
quote excited for 2020 and the next
decade with you Artem I said yes in
France in November we've been trying to
keep it a secret but really wanted to
share our excitement for the new year
and Artem wrote you are the best thing
that has ever happened to me so excited
for what's to come
I love you more than anything and thank
you for saying yes
oh and that ring it's estimated to be
between 20,000 and 40,000 dollars so I
loved meeting Artem and getting to know
him and spending time with him the pair
first met on Dancing with the Stars
Nikki was Artem's partner in 2017 at the
time she was engaged to John Cena though
they called things off in 2018 John and
I we absolutely love each other and we
care about each other a lot we are best
friends and right now we're both giving
each other time separately I love Nicole
wall-mount and that's it soon after
Nikki and Artem became inseparable with
their first official date in December
2018 I feel like the first time ever I'm
focusing on me it's crazy I never in my
life would have thought that like I
would have had a lot in common with the
Russian
[Music]
yeah you know you just can't help
chemistry and love and I don't know will
forever be in the honeymoon see what
they all say until they get married
[Music]